how are you both doing today
good hi steve how are you first of all
congrats on the movie you guys did such
a fantastic job um but i am curious dude
when you got cast who was the most
excited in your immediate family and
friends that you got the part i'm not
sure actually
was your mom your dad
yeah i think my mom and dad were really
like excited because they're like whoa
this person's in it this person's worked
with these people before and he had no
clue who any of us were
probably very healthy no i did i knew
you all from millions of different
things
yeah i read i read in the press notes
that you saw paddington in nursery
school and it made me feel very old
oh this i'll say it like that which by
the way you're you're a kid it's fine
it's totally cool all right for him
my
um what does it actually mean to because
the movie has been getting such great
reviews and i'm just curious if you've
been paying attention to that and what
does it mean to each of you to have so
many people loving the movie it's just
amazing to be honest
and i'm really happy that everyone's
enjoying the film and i think ken and
the entire casting crew really deserve
it because
everyone put their blood sweat and tears
into making it
yeah it's really lovely uh steve to hear
people talking about i haven't uh read
reviews i don't know if they've come out
but just to hear when we talk with
people about it how it affects them and
uh how they how the story touches them
very much and at the same time
what uh what joy they get from watching
it and especially watching this young
for that
you know it's really good we had a
premiere in belfast for belfast about
three nights ago and that was
a very emotional experience for all of
us it was like bringing it home
and uh for the most part people really
really got on with it yeah if i'm not
mistaken you grew up in
belfast and you were i think 16 when
this film actually takes place
i could be wrong about this but i think
i've done my research
i could say no you're wrong i was too
but that would be like
um yeah no i would have been 16. so i
was being a of a teenager at the time
and it was
it was quite a
yeah it was quite a a moment when the
year before there had been civil rights
marches and there'd been stuff starting
to happen some kind of violent uh
reaction to it and then suddenly it all
kicked off in august of 69 and uh
it was around for the next uh 25 26
years that as it escalated
and that is part of our history and it's
something that we have still are trying
to address and all that but what i
really like about the film is that it's
there in the background it's not being
ignored but it's not the heart of the
matter the heart of the matter is the
people
and how they cope in adversity and how
they reach out to each other and give
helping hands and not being too
sentimental either you know it's tough
uh but i certainly i do believe ken has
made a most beautiful film
no 100 um jude this is your first movie
and i'm curious what what surprised you
about making a movie that you didn't
expect when you started
probably how nice the entire cast was
and the crew
and ah shucks
we all just bonded like a family to be
honest and
they just became my friends and they're
really really nice people that was
probably what i'm surprised about
if i'm not mistaken you guys because of
the pandemic you guys were sort of like
locked down together while you were
making the movie and i would imagine
that actually had to have helped in the
whole bonding of everybody and making
yourself feel like a family was that the
case yeah it was i mean also uh
i guess we
were we were kept in the same hotel but
at the same time they were asking us uh
not to mix
you know not
at the same time it wasn't that you were
in a bubble so like please everybody you
know apart from the work
keep to your own rooms
use room service you if you can but just
uh keep separate and when we were in
uh waiting to go on set we were all in
separate rooms i mean came to it very
very seriously about protecting
people older people because they weren't
quite sure what was going to happen and
it was one of the first films to
actually go ahead so he had a system in
place that was very very protective and
very careful of everybody
and maybe it just focused everybody
to that when the mass the only people
who took the masks off were the actors
and they wore masks all the time until
they got in front of camera and then
they had makeup hardly bothered with it
but just use soft mass and then maybe
concentrated everybody wonderfully to
focus in those moments
when you were free without the mask and
then we felt very much connected in our
own world well i know that this was a
very personal film for kenneth obviously
i mean very personal what was it
actually like collaborating with him on
set can you guys each share like a
memory
it was he's such an amazing guy
and
probably every single second the camera
wasn't rolling we were either playing
football or just having a nice chat
and ken supports tottenham hotspurs
which i don't support that well
but and i support liverpool and
yeah that's the only thing that's a bit
iffy about him
it's the only thing
yeah that's about the only thing he's a
spurs supporter i mean apart from that
the man's a genius
uh truly um now i remember actually
there was one thing ken asked me to do
and i didn't understand why he said i
could just do it and see what happens
and he just left me on my own outside
the little house that we terraced house
we were in and he said i'm just going to
walk by off camera and shout a few
things at you
it was very funny because he went back
into his belfast but he was behind
camera and shouted a few things at me
and i went into my belfast and showed a
few ridiculous belfast sayings back at
him uh and then he just walked and said
well that's fine we'll see what happens
to that well it ended in a bin but
anyway it was fun to do at the time what
ended up being
the tough scene like a tough scene for
each of you and why maybe you had the
giggles maybe it was just a tough day on
set you know
i think
every scene that we all giggled at
jamie dornan started the girl and then
he got us all
all over oh and if there was any problem
it was jamie dornan's fault that's all
we know
me every single time
i remember we had a lovely scene about
which didn't make the final edit about
um eating tripe
which is cows innards which is a very
belfast dish it's pretty gruesome and a
cow has four stomachs i'm not going to
boy with this i'll be like no i won't
but i actually had a scene where i had
to tell him about which part of the of
the cow's stomach you eat of the four
different levels and i
i could i'd started making it up because
i forgot which bit of the kind of
stomach was which
but they cut the scene anyway
yeah and
another saying the pigs trotters saying
four miles back in the pig's trotters
this smelled and looked disgusting and i
wasn't acting whenever i nearly threw up
with them
on that note i have to stop i'm just
going to say seriously congrats um i
wish you guys nothing but the best and i
hope the film's a huge hit thank you so
much thank you thank you very much